- Hi, Adobe Creative Educators.
Welcome back to our Adobe
Creative Educator show.
We're very excited to
be here with you today
and have some very incredible
guests that are joining us.
But if you're just joining
us from Facebook, YouTube,
or Twitter, please post in
the chat what you're teaching,
where you're joining us from.
We'd love to get to know a
little bit more about you.
And I see already some folks joining in.
We have Tarek joining
us from Egypt, welcome,
and we have Jessica joining
us from Gwinnett county,
Jessica, you know, we just
did an event earlier today,
so it's really great
to see you joining us.
So again, this is live show,
so you do have the opportunity
to ask questions live,
and join with other educators
from our international Adobe
Creative Educator program.
But for those who I haven't
had the pleasure of meeting,
I'm Clara, I manage our
Educator Community Programs
here at Adobe.
And as I mentioned, this
is a very special edition
of our Adobe Creative Educator show.
So as you know, every month we're focusing
on a different theme
here and have challenges
throughout the year for you
to create remixable
templates with your students
and with other educators.
And this month, our theme is,
cultivating creative
confidence with your students.
And now we know, especially
in the month of April
during testing season, this
is something that is prevalent
in all classrooms around
the country within the US,
and even around the world.
So we're thrilled today
to be joined by Sal Khan,
of Khan Academy, the CEO of Khan Academy,
and you're gonna be hearing
from him, his perspectives,
and also have the opportunity
to ask some questions live in the chat.
But without further ado,
I'm gonna bring Sal on.
So Sal, thank you so much
for joining us today.
How are you?
- I'm doing well.
Thanks for having me, Clara.
- We're so excited to
have you on the show.
And for the vast majority of our audience,
you likely need to introduction,
but just to kick us off,
could you please introduce
a little bit more about
yourself and share more
about your current mission at Khan Academy
and how it's evolved since
you founded it 14 years ago.
- Sure, Sal Khan, founder
and CEO Khan Academy,
which as you introduced
to us, many people know
we're not for profit organization
with a mission of providing
a free world class education
for anyone anywhere.
And as you mentioned, it started
over actually 14 years ago.
Well, 14 years ago was
actually when we did set up
as a not-for-profit, but
it started back in 2004
as a tutoring project where I
was an analyst at a hedge fund
and I started tutoring one
family member remotely,
I was in Boston, she was in new Orleans.
That went well, it was helping her,
I became what I call a tiger cousin.
I started tutoring more cousins.
Before I knew it, word spread in my family
that free tutoring was going on,
and I was tutoring 10 or 15 cousins.
And I saw patterns that the reason
why they were oftentimes struggling
was because they just had
gaps in their knowledge.
So I started writing software for them,
my original background was in software.
So I did this as a hobby for them
to get as much practice as they want.
And then a friend suggested
that I make videos
to supplement the software.
I thought it was a silly idea at first,
but I gave it a shot,
and those videos also took
on a life of their own.
And by 2008 is when I formally
incorporated Khan Academy
and set it up as a not-for-profit.
You know, you fast forward to today,
what started with a handful of cousins
is now 130 million red registered users,
about 30 million folks come
every month to the platform,
we're in 50 languages around the world.
But our mission, free
world class education
for anyone anywhere is
still the same mission.
And our vision is,
can we offer all of the
core academic content
from pre-K through the core of college
for anyone in the world,
everyone in the world,
in all the world's major languages?
Can we do it in a way
that really meets students where they are?
And so these are principles,
I'm happy to talk more about
it, of personalization,
empowering students,
meeting them where they are,
mastery learning, which is
always having the opportunity,
the incentive to improve where you are,
instead of just getting a C and moving on,
keep working on it so that
you can get to 90% or 100%.
And then the third
pillar of our vision is,
how can we make that learning translate
into real opportunity?
Getting into college, get a
job, whatever it might be.
So come a long way since those early days,
but still a long way to go.
We aspire to empower
billions hopefully over time.
- Thank you so much for
sharing that background.
And I know there's a lot of educators
in our international community
that are using Khan Academy.
And I'm just popping over here
to seeing some of the chat.
We have Benjamin joining us from England,
Rachel, joining us from Texas,
and Tim, hi Tim, from New York, says,
"I'm excited to learn more
about Khan Academy today,
have some amazing resources."
So we're looking forward
to diving more into that.
And Rebecca, who's going
to be joining us here
at a moment live, says, "I
love the tiger cousin role."
So it's great to hear those
origins of Khan Academy
that we know and love,
here in the International
Educator Community.
But we also have another
guest joining us today.
So I'm gonna bring him
on here in a moment.
Hey, Ben, how's it going?
- Hello there, good to be here.
- So Ben is here on our team
and also our director of education,
but Ben leads an incredible
team of evangelists
and community members and
community leaders here at Adobe.
And Ben, you're quite the
legend in your experience
in education, including
your tenure at Adobe.
So can you share a little
bit more about yourself
and your background?
- Sure, not sure about
legend, but thank you.
Yeah, I have a wonderful
team here at Adobe.
We focus on helping
K12 educators worldwide
inject creativity in the
classroom in very meaningful ways.
I am an educator myself,
I've been teaching for over 30 years.
I'm also an author, I've
written 40 plus books
that have taught coding
to over a million people.
And actually more relevance
to our topic today,
my most recent book use game coding
to introduce creative thinking
and creative problem solving
for middle and high school students.
So that's what we do, we
spend a lot of time thinking
about creativity and how
to help K12 teachers.
And it's a pleasure to be here.
- Thank you for joining us, Ben and Sal.
I know we have a great
conversation ahead of us,
in particular, focusing
on mastery learning
and creative confidence in the classroom.
But Sal, in particular for Khan Academy,
how do you see educators in the community
cultivating a creative
confidence in their students?
- Well, you know, I think
creativity can only happen
when there's space for it.
And so, I think it's important.
I think about this as a parent as well.
You know, when I was a kid,
my family didn't have a lot of resources,
and so like, I was bored a lot,
but that boredom, you know,
I was like, okay, there's some
pencil, there's some paper,
I guess I'm gonna do something,
I used to draw a lot.
And you know, at the time I
remember I used to envy the kids
who could go to these fancy summer camps
and do this and do that, and
those things can be very nice.
But I now realize in my own childhood,
there was something nice about that,
boredom fostering creativity,
and making you learn
to make things as opposed to
kind of being directed always
on what you should do.
So I think about this as a parent now,
'cause I now do have the resources
and my kids probably are
getting overscheduled.
And I'm like, "Oh, am I
squeezing out the time
for some of their creativity?"
And I also sometimes in classrooms,
I think teachers can feel
a in on them to like,
"Hey, I gotta make sure that
every second of this classroom
is productive for my students.
And that's a good instinct,
although sometimes I think
it is nice to create,
you need some guardrails
for the students and
some objectives for them,
but then give them a little bit of space,
give them a little bit of
space to potentially fail,
to have a larger variance
in what they might produce.
And I think those are the
areas where you can let
that creativity, which I
think all human beings have.
But a can atrophy if it's
not given enough space
and enough time.
And obviously it can
happen at every level.
You know, a lot of people
think of creativity,
they think of an artist splashing paint
on canvas or something like that.
That's obviously one form of creativity.
But creativity can even happen
when you're looking at an equation.
And kind of the non-creative form
of processing the equation is,
"All right, I just plug numbers into it,
and it gives me an answer."
The creative form is like,
"What does this mean?
How does this connect to other things?
Can I draw connections with it?
Can I manipulate it to
have it express in new ways
that tell me other
things about the universe
that it can connect to other ideas?"
So, I think it can happen in anything,
but you need some time and space for it.
- Absolutely, I'm seeing
here in the chat too,
educators really resonating
with their own experiences.
And Sally, I love how you mentioned
how creativity is not just the arts.
And I think that's
sometimes a misconception
that we see in schools,
but it's that whole making connections.
And what is the creative thinking
process look like in math,
look like in English
language, arts and sciences?
One of the things that
we see in our community,
and I know in Khan Academy as well,
is that their educators from
all different subject areas.
So as you said, just providing that space
and that opportunity for students
to have that freedom is so powerful.
And, Ben, anything to
add to that in terms of
what you've been seeing at Adobe?
- Yeah, so I echo everything Sal said,
we need to reach students and educators.
And when it comes to reaching students,
honestly, not much as needed,
it's get out of the way,
give them room to play,
give them the latitude
to experiment and fail,
and give them license to
iterate, permission to discover,
find their own voice, that's
actually the easy part.
The trickier part we find
are the teachers themselves.
They are overwhelmed, they
have often strict guidelines
and constraints that
they have to adhere to.
And the last thing we ever
wanna do is give them more work,
that's unrealistic, it's
also frankly disrespectful.
And so we spend a lot of
time working with educators
to help them understand
how to meaningfully inject
creativity in every subject,
as you just noted in a very relevant way.
You know, we have the tools,
we think we have the best
tools for them to be using.
We have great content on
our education exchange,
including all the materials created
in partnership at Khan Academy.
And so we work with school
districts and leads,
with trainers, and our focus
is to help them understand
the how, how to be less
prescriptive, which Sal alluded to,
how to rethink assignments,
how to rethink the balance
of lecturing verses doing,
how to rethink students taking agency
in finding their own path?
And we do this with
training, with mentoring,
with professional development,
participation in our Adobe
Creative Educator community.
And all of these, the
goal of all these programs
is really to empower
educators with the confidence
to let the students do what
they naturally do best.
- And I know part of that,
Ben, as you mentioned,
are the tools, and I know we'll dive
into some of the tools that are offered
and possible for educators later.
But absolutely, and kind of looking
at across all subject areas,
providing the freedom,
providing the space
for them to be creative
is again so powerful.
And I'm seeing some
comments in the chat here.
Tim says, "I love giving students
and myself some free time and space,
boredom can be a terrific breeding ground
for creativity and imagination."
And so I think really
brought that well together.
And I see Kuben, nice
to see you joining us
from Johannesburg in South Africa.
And Marilyn also says,
"Appreciate the sensitivity
in regards to teachers."
So thank you they're from Marilyn.
But I know we've touched
on this a little bit
in your introduction, Sal.
But when it comes to thinking
about creative confidence
and then an overlap between
mastery mindset and creativity,
how do those all come into play together?
And especially during April,
during testing season,
how can educators really approach
these three pieces together,
of mastery, mindset and creativity?
- Yeah, and I'll add another dimension
of growth mindset to that.
You know, it's very in Vogue these days
to talk about the growth mindset,
there's obviously a lot of
great research from folks
like Carol Dweck and Angela
Duckworth and other folks.
And it's all on this principle that like,
a growth mindset is better,
and it's a mindset in which
you don't stigmatize failure,
you realize that if you didn't succeed,
that's actually, and if you reflect on it,
that's actually where
you're gonna grow the most.
And if you have a stick intuitiveness,
a greater perseverance
and you keep working on it
so that you can get to a
point of fluency or mastery,
that that is how you're
going to improve the most
in almost in any domain.
Mastery learning is how
that gets implemented
in an academic setting
in my point of view.
As I hinted at, in a traditional model,
a student gets an 80% on
a test, and they kind of,
you market that down in their grade book,
and the student says, I
guess I'm a C student.
And one that probably creates
a fixed mindset on one level,
'cause you're not even
telling the student,
"Hey, why don't you
give another shot at it,
get better at it.
This isn't a bad thing that
you got some questions wrong,
those are opportunities to learn."
But it also, then those
gaps persist, which is,
I think particularly
harmful in STEM subjects,
I think is harmful in all subjects.
But if you only understood how
to divide decimals 80% well,
now all of a sudden the whole
classroom is doing equations
with decimals or doing some more,
decimal, dividing decimal word problems.
How are you going to really
be able to master that
if you couldn't understand
the more fundamental idea.
And so I think, mastery,
which is in my definition is,
always having the opportunity incentive
to improve your state.
I think it's important for developing
the tools so that you can
express yourself creatively.
You know, I think if you look
at the field of mathematics,
the fields of science, these
are clearly creative fields.
You're trying to come up with new ways
of describing reality, new
ways of understand reality,
new ways of engineering, new
ways of inventing things.
And I think the reason why
sometimes there's a stereotype
that it's not, is because
so much time and effort
goes behind building the competencies
so that you can be creative in the space.
It's kind of like if we
were trying to be artists,
but you know, for the first 12 years
you're just learning to mix paint,
you'll never get to be the artist,
or you're learning to be a dancer,
but for the first 12
years you're stretching,
and you never get to really
express yourself through dance.
And so I'm a big fan of,
mastery learning's gonna build
those competencies so
you feel that confidence
so that when you do engage on,
Hey, why does the Krebs cycle
work this way in biology?
Or, what are these different forms
of an equation really tell you?
you need that fluency in
order to be able to dig
into the conversation, but then it unlocks
an incredibly creative one.
And the more that we can bring
some of what real math petition do,
what real scientists do into
the classroom, all the better.
But I will say, historically,
there's been a schism
with educators where
there's been what you call
the progressive educators.
That's like, "Yes, let's bring this all in
to the classroom tomorrow or right now
where kids are acting as scientists,
acting as mathematicians,
acting as historians."
And then you have of your
traditionalists who say,
"Well, no, no, the kids really
need to have their fluency,
really need to be able to solve
certain types of problems."
I generally think it's both.
You really can't activate a
lot of the creative, you can't,
you know, the scientists who
are thinking like scientists
have a lot of content knowledge
and have a lot of fluency.
And if they don't, they're
gonna have trouble thinking
like a scientist in a lot of cases.
So, can you use mastery learning,
tools like Khan Academy,
other tools, to get that foundation,
and then hopefully free
up time for more of
the creative aspects,
which exist in every field.
- Absolutely, and that
whole process of iteration
and having a growth mindset and continuing
to fail along the way is something
that we've seen just even within design
and creating different visual
concepts and communicating.
So I know it's something
within our community,
we've seen quite a bit as well.
And, Ben, from the Adobe side,
anything to add to that
in terms of mastery,
mastery learning and the growth mindset?
- Yeah, I'll add to that,
obviously creativity
is a foundational skill, right?
It's about agency, it's
about finding your own voice,
it's about iteration.
And nurturing that creative thinking,
nurturing creative problem solving
and creative covers in general,
those are critical to
developing a growth mindset
at your own pace, which
is literally mastery.
You know, I'm a huge fan of
Sir. Ken Robinson's definition
that creativity is the process
of having original ideas that have value.
And in that definition, the
world that's most important
to me is original, the unique, the idea
that we're encouraging a
child to find their own path.
That isn't necessarily exactly the same
as the kids sitting next to
him or her in the classroom.
And this is real and
meaningful and impactful.
And it has recognized implications
both short term and long term, right?
There's lots of research
that shows the impact,
short term impact on education
up comes in the classroom,
but it has long term
implications for future success.
Look, I don't want education
to ever be solely driven
by jobs and hiring trends, right?
We don't wanna be, you know,
in first grade worrying
about what occupation
you'll have 20 years down the line,
we want well-rounded students.
But at the same time, we can't
ignore future opportunities,
and industry doesn't
want more of the same.
You never hear a company
saying, "I love this employee,
I want 1000 more exactly the
same as him or her," right?
We want diversity, we want
it not just for diversity,
but also diverse thoughts,
diverse problem solving,
diverse thinking, diverse backgrounds,
diverse voices, that's critical.
And we have to nurture that.
And if we fail to encourage that unique,
honestly we are being
kids of their future.
And for us, that's what creativity
in the classroom is all about,
and that creativity must be nurtured.
And the truth is, tying back
to where we started off,
nurturing creativity is
truly encouraging mastery.
- Absolutely, and I know
that speaking of jobs
of the future, we don't know
what a lot of those physicians will be,
but what we do know is if
you have a growth mindset,
you can think creatively, you
can make those connections,
you can iterate along the way,
approach problems from different angles,
that's what's going to be successful,
and ultimately what
employers are looking for.
So, and going quickly
to the comments here,
we do have comments from the chat.
So we have Timothy joining
us from Canada says,
"Traditionally, math has
never been recognized
as being creative.
Students can produce instructional videos
with a creative element based on math."
So some ideas to kind
of bring in creativity
into the process.
And Tim says, "Agreed!
I think one of the strengths
of all online tools
is that they allow that self-paced
kind of personalized
individualized learning."
So, and then goes on to say, great points.
"Diversity brings value in
with different perspectives and ideas."
So again, if you're watching
live, this is a live show.
So go ahead and post in the
chat if you have comments,
questions, it's a great
opportunity to our speakers live."
- I will add on some of those comments,
I love the idea of making videos,
obviously I spent a
lot of time doing that.
And there is, if especially maths,
actually any subject
math, science, humanities,
one of the most direct ways of
applying creativity is, yeah,
ask students to make
artifacts, explainers, videos,
or even to tutor each other,
'cause if you have to,
if you think about it, when
you have to tutor someone else,
it's an incredibly creative process.
You have to model their
mind and then think
about creative pathways
that might unlock certain
concepts in their mind.
We have actually a platform
called schoolhouse.world,
which is another not-for-profit,
which does free tutoring,
where people volunteer
to tutor other people.
So if you, that's for
13 years old and over,
but another great outlet
to flex creativity
in a very direct way.
- That's great.
And that's schoolhouse.world,
we can go ahead and put
that in the chat, great.
Well, thank you so much
for this great discussion,
and we'll get back to
some of these points.
But within every live stream,
we go through the creative process,
speaking of iterating and
going through that process
of define, create and reflect.
So many Adobe Creative Educators
know this process well.
But with that, we're
gonna actually move on
to our Create Portion where
we're gonna have the opportunity
to get hands on with
Creative Cloud Express
and actually co-create
alongside Sal Khan our April challenge.
So as we move to the Create Portion,
I'm gonna go ahead and bring
up my colleague, Rebecca Hare.
Hey Rebecca.
- Hey.
- And I'm thrilled to
announce that Rebecca
has joined our team full-time
and is our education
community program manager,
and as we know, the architect behind
the Adobe Creative Educator Course.
Rebecca, do you wanna introduce yourself
really quickly before we dive in?
- Yeah, I'm really excited
to work Sal on this
and get the graphic going.
Been a teacher for almost eight years,
and a designer before that.
So I love working with creative educators
and coming up with ways to
make learning come alive
for students, that's kind
of our big focus right now.
So, I'm gonna go ahead
and share my screen.
We'll get started right now.
Sal, this is our Creative
Educator Challenge for this month.
We have a student challenge, which is,
I am more than a score.
And there is a template that
students can get started with
and some videos to get them started
so they could do this at their own pace.
And then of course, we always start off
with a teacher challenge as well,
so that they can feel comfortable with it
before they get started in the classroom.
So when we click on
that, you get a template
and it's really fun because
you just click this,
remix this design, and it opens up for you
in Creative Cloud Express,
and it's just a prompt to get you started.
So you're not stuck with
this design or colors
or anything else.
So we're gonna first,
your job right now, Sal,
is to start thinking about
the words you're gonna change.
I happen to have an image of you,
so I'm gonna go ahead and change that out.
So when you art and
Creative Cloud Express,
it's always a great idea
to click on the art board.
And then you can open up
the Layers panel over here.
So I'm gonna click on one of these images
of our default image, and
I'm gonna click Replace.
And then I can upload images.
So I have in my Great
American Educators folder,
a picture of you, there we go.
And it will magically
take away your background,
apply all the same filters
that we've done to this.
And then you are magically inside.
- Well, that's pretty cool.
- Already ready to go.
Pretty fun, right?
- I was just laughing.
How many people have a Great
American Educators folder
on their.
- I think educator.
I have them actually
categorized by centuries as well
and geographic locations.
So, you made the cut,
there's only six in there.
- Yeah, I question your
judgment, but let's go on.
(Rebecca laughs)
- I stand behind my choices.
So says pink as you can see,
and maybe not your favorite color,
maybe your favorite color,
what's really fun with
this is this is actually
just a filter effect that we can do.
So if you click down on
this, it's a duotone effect,
so it gives us like
really fun filter to it.
So we can inside of Creative
Cloud Express, click on this,
and then I can use the color picker tool,
which is like high level
photo shop kind of thing,
and change the color of your image
to any color that we have.
Or of course I can go through
other kinds of pieces.
So I'm actually gonna find
it from the Khan logo,
which is this kind of green here,
and I can change you and change the color.
And then I can go through
and change and click on
through my layers, change
all of these other graphics.
But as you were chatting, I
went ahead and was tinkering
with that and have sort
of started a design.
I don't know how you feel about it.
We can change it and make it anything
you want it to be.
- Looking good.
(Rebecca laughs)
- I did go in and I took some screenshots
of some of the illustrations
that are the Khan website,
which I really liked as
kind of a background.
And I was able to bring that
same kind of green color in
as well, and I found
the same color in here.
So how do you feel
about the design so far?
I'm happy to make any
changes that you want.
- I'm liking it.
Maybe if we have more than one color.
- Yeah, more than one color, absolutely.
So we can actually, this
is really fun because,
again, I click on the thing,
I go through maybe one
of your lighter colors,
we can maybe change your center.
You have another color
you can, so first of all,
I'd ask you like what
your favorite colors are.
When we go over here,
we can go through and choose on the more,
there is a great color palette
with tons and tons of colors,
or we can pick something
for any color that you want.
If you know the hex code
off the top of your head,
I'd be super impressed.
- I don't have hex favorite hex codes,
but what's a good.
I guess, like a pastel, like a warm,
like green and red or
complimentary, right?
- Yeah.
- This is like a yellow.
- What happens if I do this red?
That's kind of fun.
- Yeah, looking good.
- You like that?
We could also make it more of the orange.
- Yeah, I like that, that's good.
- Awesome.
And then, if what's fun about this
is we brought that in there.
If we wanted to go just
a little bit darker,
I could click on that and actually go in
and just make it a tiny bit
darker or a little bit more red.
So we see your picture
a little bit better.
And if I don't, I can
go back and just find
that orange again and
switch you back out again.
So that's the fun thing, and
you can do the same thing
to all of these shapes
and features will come in.
What's really great is
we have shapes over here.
And so, I just searched up a blob.
You can search up anything.
So give me a word to
search up that you think
we will not have a shape for.
- Is there like, a shape
word would be the word?
- No, just anything.
- Spiral.
- I'll go with spiral.
Oh, now I'm worried.
I'm not gonna spell spiral
correctly 'cause I'm live.
- I-R (laughs)
Trust me, while I've been
making on Khan Academy videos,
the spelling, I know
how it is writing words.
- I always live spelling,
everything goes totally out the window.
- This is a no judgment zone.
- I appreciate that.
This is our growth mindset.
I'm learning how to spell the word spiral.
So tons of spirals in
here, it's a fun thing
we can kind of bring those in.
And what's great about this.
I'm not sure if there's a specific spiral
that you like the best.
- Yeah, some of those are hypnotic.
- I know they really are,
they might be too much,
but we can always throw them in.
They'll come in with a default color
and then we can change that,
we can change the size of them.
We can rotate them, we
can move them around,
we can even change where
they are so I can go in.
I do have this, I can
go color picker this.
This is actually the hex code of your blue
in the Khan colors.
So I could throw this spiral
back here and actually just go
and say, drop it down to the back
so I could bring some other
kinds of colors in as well.
Every time I click on anything,
that panel opens for properties,
but we should probably focus on words.
So any words that you have in this,
while I was listening to you speak
some things I brought in
were, if I click on here,
you can go, I heard you say reflective.
And so I added that word
in, right now we have,
you're more than a
scorer, you're creative,
you're collaborative, you're courageous,
reflective, resilient,
any other words you wanna
change or add out for students?
- And these are things to
tell students to remind them.
- Yeah, that they're more
than just a grade, because,
or whatever happens on that test.
Like that's really important,
and we learn so much about that,
but we're so much bigger
than just that test.
- Yeah, I mean, you
know, I meditate a lot,
and I meditate on, you
know, I'm not the body,
I am not the mind, I am pure awareness,
but maybe that's a little
bit too metaphysical.
- Oh, I like that.
- I do find it very
liberating when you're,
even this mind that is throwing out
all these crazy thoughts,
that's not quite me.
I'm the observer of the mind.
- How about you are more than a mind?
- Yeah, or yeah.
Even, I mean, it's getting
at a level, you are.
- Pure awareness.
So we have two different.
- You're pure awareness.
You are the awareness.
- We can turn this into it.
We have a spiral, we're
almost like at a labyrinth,
then we have a meditation.
- You might have to throw
a big O symbol there
for the dimension.
(Rebecca laughs)
- I also heard you say,
about the creative process,
being like an inspired learner,
inspired by your surroundings,
so I added that in.
Artists, thinker, scholar, supportive,
determined, persistent.
- I dunno if this is about,
but I always tell young people,
I remind older people all the time, like,
you know, you can help
me on the right word,
but like, we get so caught up
with the mundane day to day
that stresses us out, but we
like lose sight of the fact
that we're like we're
aware in this universe,
that is for the most part
a mystery and like just
the wonder of being able to explore it,
so maybe you're an explorer.
- I love that, explorer.
- You know, the wonder,
you're an Explorer of
the Wonder of the Cosmos
of reality itself.
Like, you know, every one of
us, it's like an adventure,
and we forget it while
we're doing our taxes
and trying to turn in
tomorrow's assignment.
(Sal laughs)
- How's that, Explorer of
the Wonder of the Cosmos,
is that right?
- Yeah, why not?
- I love it.
I think I might have
gotten a little bit big,
but that's okay, we have all these.
What's so fun about this
is that we've done this
and thousands of educators
have already done this,
and actually a few thousand
students have already done this,
it just launched for them on Monday.
And it's so beautiful to see
just with a couple of prompts
how everyone's response
to this is so you unique
and they changed the words,
how they think about themselves
and how they think about their students.
And so that's what we're
really trying to do
with these challenges
is to give just enough
that people take it and
make it completely uniquely
and beautifully their own.
So we could spend more minutes on this,
and I know that we're kind of,
we're probably out of time,
but it was so great to hear you speak.
And I'll tinker with us a little
bit more and then send this
on over to you.
But thanks so much for
creating with us today
on Creative Cloud Express.
- Thank you, this is a lot of fun.
- Well, thank you, Sal and Rebecca and Ben
for joining us today.
And I'm just gonna put
a quick reminder here.
So we'd love for you to
create your own graphic,
we'll be sharing out Sal's
later for inspiration.
But if you go to the link
below, Adobe.ly/EDU,aprilstpg
and we put that in the chat as well,
you can create your own image,
and then we'd love for you
to share that with the
hashtag Adobe EDU Creative,
so that we see all of that,
no matter what time zone you're end,
you can go ahead and
post your image in there.
But before we sign off today,
a big thank you again to Sal,
to Ben, to Rebecca, and
quick closing comments.
Sal, for those who want to stay
in touch with Khan Academy,
stay in touch with you,
what are the best social
channels or website to check out?
- Yeah, we have, both I, I
think it's Sal Khan Academy,
and then we have Khan Academy
on all the major social channels, Twitter,
Instagram, Facebook, LinkedIn,
I've gotten more active.
Actually, I have a TikTok,
look for me there too.
Our neighbors convinced
me to get on TikTok.
But this was really fun.
And I do think, I agree with
Ben, this is fundamental,
you know, creativity underpins everything.
- Well, be sure to check the
out those social channels,
and that TikTok sounds like a lot of fun.
And Ben, in terms of your social channels,
I see your handle,
anything else you wanna
share with educators?
- Yeah, I'm not younger
or cool enough as Sal
to have TikTok, so you
can find me @benforta
or online at forter.com and I
love hearing from everybody.
- Thank you, and Rebecca.
- Oh, I'm just excited to see,
learn how to dance from Sal,
on the TikTok channel,
that's how I can't get
anything else out of it.
I'm gonna learn all the new dances.
- Well, thank you all
again for joining us,
and be sure to use the
hashtag Adobe EDU Creative
in your takeaways from today.
But have a wonderful rest of your week.
We look forward to
seeing all of your images
and continuing to inspire
creative confidence
in all of your students.
We'll see you next month
for our next live stream.
Bye everyone.
- Good bye.